construye un círculo que circunscriba al
triángulo es decir un círculo que se
encuentre en el círculo centro del
triángulo o en el punto en donde se
intersectan las líneas perpendiculares
que se encuentran justo a la mitad de
cada uno de los lados del triángulo y
además este círculo debe tocar todos los
vértices del triángulo te damos nuestras
herramientas el compás la regla y borrar
bueno vamos a encontrar los puntos
medios de cada lado del triángulo para
eso necesitamos el compás
ya que necesitamos circunferencias que
sean un poco más grandes
bueno las voy a poner en el vértice y
deben ser un poco más grandes que la
mitad del lado que estoy tratando de
dividir a la mitad necesito un círculo
con la circunferencia igual a el que
dibuje anteriormente y este lo voy a
mover a este otro vértice muy bien y en
la línea que une estos dos puntos de
aquí donde se intersectan los círculos
las circunferencias va a ser justo el
que esté a la mitad de mí
lado del triano ok
y esta línea divide en partes iguales
este lado del triángulo y es
perpendicular a este mismo lado vamos a
hacer lo mismo para otro lado del
triángulo pero este lado es un poquito
más chico entonces voy a reducir estas
circunferencias y ahora que las tenemos
del mismo tamaño vamos a tomar una
circunferencia y colocarla en este otro
vértice utilizamos la regla y unimos
estos dos puntos de intersección entre
las circunferencias y aquí ya tengo otra
línea que es perpendicular a este lado y
que lo divide a la mitad ahora voy a
poder poner un círculo justo aquí en la
intersección de estos dos elementos es
cierto círculo ya no me sirve lo hago a
un lado lo hago más chiquito y este
círculo lo redimensionar para que toque
los tres vértices del triángulo más o
menos así
veamos comprobar respuesta
correcto